[Applaudissements]
pariez sur aude mouvoir aussi donc c'est
ma première ici c'est quoi c'est la
première fois que vous venez premier
record il paraît qu'un cadeau prend une
bouteille d'eau gazeuse c'est pour moi
frérot voilà c'est aussi un cadeau de
bienvenue tout le monde repart avec ce
qu il paraît que vous pendant les
tournages lisait beaucoup entre les
prises c'est ce que me dit tout le monde
ah bon c'est pas vrai mais c'est bien
c'est bon aussi pour me dire à chaque
fois arié il y est tout ça et là il est
dans ces trucs non c'est pas vrai et
c'est eux
oui ligue et répète je crois que je les
fais ni sur le tournage que je connais
bien votre frère kad merad et fera
cadeau n'est pas vrai je sais exactement
non
[Applaudissements]
mais dégage la rive droite cassée
polnareff julien lepers oh non mais moi
personnellement je trouve c'est le
meilleur de la raison c'est vrai quoi il
ya de lait pur il n'en rajoute pas il
est seulement par vous il est bien
parier je vais vous dire il a l'oeil